[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: BigQuery
is a fully managed
petabyte-scale low-cost
analysis warehouse.
You can access and
share analytics insights
in your organization
with a few clicks.
While BigQuery has robust
security and governance
controls to keep your data
safe within your organization,
it's important to
keep sensitive data
inaccessible to
unauthorized third parties
and reduce data
exfiltration risks.
Event Threat Detection
is a built-in service
for the Security
Command Center premium
tier that continuously
monitors your organization
and identifies threats within
your system in near real time.
It includes a finding type for
BigQuery data exfiltration,
which can help alert you when
an unauthorized actor attempts
to extract or expose
sensitive data in BigQuery,
whether on purpose
or by accident.
BigQuery data exfiltration
works by examining audit logs
for two scenarios--
a resource is saved
outside your organization,
or a copy operation is attempted
that's blocked by VPC Service
Controls, or an attempt
is made to access
BigQuery resources that are
protected by VPC Service
Controls.
In order to use BigQuery
data exfiltration,
first enable Event Threat
Detection with an SCC premium
subscription.
If you want to set
up ETD, check out
our episode on how to use
Event Threat Detection.
Let's imagine a malicious
actor was tasked with stealing
the financial data set from the
organization GCP-SEC-DEMO-ORG.
They attempt to push results
to an external table located
in a different Google Cloud
organization, project,
and BigQuery destination table.
If the GCP-SEC-DEMO-ORG
organization did not have ETD
enabled, the malicious actor
can quickly perform the query
and extract data to another
project under a new table
if they have the
right permissions.
While the action is logged, it
happens mostly under the radar.
By the time someone notices,
the job will be complete,
and the data has likely
been exfiltrated.
Luckily, this organization
has enabled ETD.
And when the malicious
actor attempts,
ETD will surface the
finding immediately,
including when it
was discovered,
the category, under
Source Properties,
the project found in,
and data associated
with the exfiltration attempt
including the detection
category and rules--
exfiltration to an external
table, and jobState SUCCEEDED.
Below, you can find the
destination BigQuery data set
and table IDs and the person
who submitted the job.
The finding directly
links to the job,
so that if the job
had not yet succeeded,
you can now follow the link and
stop the job before completion.
You can also add a
VPC service perimeter
by heading to the VPC
Service Control Console.
Service perimeters are an
organization-level method
to protect Google Cloud
Services in your projects
in order to mitigate the
risk of data exfiltration.
Give it a name.
Leave perimeter type as
default. And select Enforced
mode to prevent access
to protected services.
Select the project, Restricted
Services, BigQuery API,
VPC accessible services,
Access Level, and click Save.
The idea is that the legitimate
users of the data set
are aware of the
perimeter violation.
If some malicious actor
got access to the data set
but was not aware of the
perimeter, attempting
to exfilltrate or
even legitimately use
BigQuery at all would
result in the violation
finding being generated.
Now, if the malicious
actor attempts
to exfilltrate financial
data from BigQuery
to an external table
again, they are blocked.
VPC Service
Controls-- Request is
prohibited by organization's
policy, vpcServicecontrols.
Going back to the
SCC threats page,
a new finding under the BigQuery
Data Exfiltration category
has surfaced showing the
VPC permanent violation.
Congratulations.
You've set up BigQuery
data exfiltration
using Event Threat Detection
for Security Command Center
and learned how to respond
to a finding from it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]